let's go next to our caller from the
eight five seven area code who's calling
today from eight five seven hi thanks
thanks David
this is John lot I'm actually from
Snowden but I'm calling a Google Voice
from Saudi Arabia our opinion on what's
going to happen with the whole Saudi
Arabia Iran thing and tangentially
related if you think this is gonna have
any impact on Tulsi gabbard's campaign
Tulsi yet why would it affect her
campaign because she the or at least
she's branded herself as the most Pro
peace anti-war candidate she's been you
know this is like her issue and no one
else you know it would except sort of
maybe Bernie over its really talking
about foreign policy oh yeah I saw that
she I started tweeted that um I saw she
tweeted that it's crazy for Trump to be
so subservient to Saudi Arabia which was
which was also my analysis I don't think
it's gonna have any impact on her
campaign I think I mean she wasn't even
in the last debate so I don't I don't
know that it'll do much for the campaign
but I mean it listen it is disgusting
the degree to which Donald Trump is
turning over control of foreign policy
and saying once Saudi Arabia tells us if
they agree with our assessment and once
Saudi Arabia tells us what the scope of
the response should be we are at the
ready and locked and loaded I mean it's
it's it's absolutely discussing this is
a show that for ten years has been
decrying the relationship that the
United States has with Saudi Arabia and
I don't know how its ultimate ly going
to play out I think there is a
possibility that Donald Trump is
determined to get involved in some
military conflict somewhere period
afford the benefit of his reelection and
it's not a crazy thing to do because
historically it works pretty well to
keep incumbent presidents in the White
House to be involved in what is
colloquially or legally referred to as a
war but I don't know that the direction
it's going to go at the same time Donald
Trump looks like he's going to be
signing on to this 15 15 billion dollar
idea by France to get Iran back into
compliance with the Iran nuclear deal so
it's anyone's guess and the erratic
nature of Trump makes it very difficult
to actually predict what might happen
thanks David all right appreciate the
call thank you so much